foreign
because I went to BU I was not admitted
into the business school like I wanted
to I was admitted into the General
Studies program and I'm actually doing
the business school commencement speech
in a few days so that's going to be cool
because I barely graduated I actually
almost got kicked out my name is
Daniella Pearson I am the founder and
CEO of the news at Media Group which
encompasses news at media and new land
our agency and I'm also the co-founder
of wondermind when I was growing up I
definitely had a huge fascination with
media in terms of reading magazines so I
remember going into the grocery store
Publix because I'm from Florida and my
mom just saying only one because I would
just come to the register with 10
magazines so I always wanted to work for
a magazine in terms of being an
entrepreneur
I was kind of an out of the box kid I
didn't really like school I didn't
really buy into it even you know in
middle school I would say why do I need
to know about the Earth's crust you know
I'm not going to be an expert in that I
swear and I I felt really stupid as a
kid because I'm an identical twin and my
sister Alex
is you know a genius but I ended up
being so excited for you know colleges
like I'm going to learn about what I'm
going to do and so I get there the first
day and guess what we're learning about
the Earth's [__] crust as a sophomore
I realized okay I have four years where
I'm lucky enough that I don't have to
have a job right now so this is the
perfect time for me to basically create
a job because if No One's Gonna hire me
because I have bad grades I need to hire
myself and so I made a list and I had
one column what am I good at and then
the other column is what do I love and I
am ashamed or not that ashamed now to
say but before I was ashamed to say that
I was not good at anything and literally
that column was blank and I'm not just
saying that to be humble I really was
not good at anything I had zero passions
I skills I just was kind of there and
that that was a you know eye-opener so
then I said okay well if I'm not good at
anything what do I like and the first
thing was magazines and so I thought you
know no one's going to hire me to be an
intern at these magazines I don't have
amazing grades and usually have to know
somebody who knows somebody whatever and
so why don't I just make my own magazine
but instead of it being printed what if
it was like a daily magazine almost like
a daily gift in your inbox and that's
when I came up with the news at
[Music]
the second I started the news at I felt
like even though it was this you know
shitty little newsletter that eight
people read every single day after that
I never missed today for the five years
I wrote it myself every weekday I would
wake up at 5am I would get my Fruity
Pebbles my orange juice and I would just
write it and I would literally like
finish writing and say oh my gosh it's
10 a.m like five hours went by but it
didn't even feel like it because it was
such a rush and so every time I saw my
little newsletter list grow it literally
felt like I was winning a lottery
essentially the first month when I
graduated I made twenty five thousand
dollars off of ads and I was like oh
[__] like I can do this so I moved to
New York it was just me and then I had
an intern then I had two interns and it
just kind of kept growing from there but
I think the year that we did a million
dollars in sales
without any VC funding I was really
proud because at that time the media was
only covering people with you know how
much have you raised or it was all about
you know raising money
um and I was probably 22 or 23 at the
time and I felt so embarrassed that I
wasn't able to raise any money but then
I thought you know honestly it's kind of
more impressive and I'm actually more
impressed with entrepreneurs now when I
invest in their companies it's more
impressive to convince hundreds of
customers to believe in you to make a
million dollars then convince three guys
in a board room to give you a million
dollars and so that's when I kind of
felt like maybe I don't need BC money
maybe I can actually grow this big the
next year we did 7 million and then we
did 40 million and you know by the end
of the year we are going to have over a
million subscribers and that's a big
deal to us because we could have had
over a million subscribers you know a
year or two ago but we clean our list to
make sure that only the best you know
five hundred thousand six hundred
thousand people are reading and so for
us to get to a million those are a
million people who are reading you know
almost every day they're engaging and so
they're real you know people and Views
so I have always been uh in the quality
over quantity approach for everything we
want people that are going to be so
excited to read our newsletter every
single day and almost wait for it and
like refresh their inbox until it comes
and I think our adlers because they
really are the people that are writing
the content are the people who are
reading it and it's so authentic and
there's no red tape there's no board
that we have to abide by oh don't write
about this don't write about that the
buck stops here and I I don't think I've
gotten involved in anything editorial in
years because I trust the people on my
team uh it's just whatever our readers
want to read about let's write about
that Pearson is also a coach founder of
wondermind a platform for exploring and
maintaining one's mental health its
underlying philosophy is that mental
Wellness requires daily effort the same
way that achieving physical fitness
requires regular exercise the company
first announced in November of 2021
raised five million dollars in August of
2022 from Serena Williams's Venture
Capital firm Serena Ventures valuing the
pre-revenue startup at 100 million
dollars I have OCD which is
obsessive-compulsive disorder ADHD and
depression and those were things that
you know even just a few years ago I
would have rather you know just had the
there's a saying in in Spanish where
have the Earth just like rip open and
eat me up uh rather than say I have OCD
or ADHD or anything having to do with
mental health
when I spoke on the Forbes 3 under 30
panel and I left the auditorium after I
was done and I was standing there and we
all of a sudden were bombarded by this
huge line of other entrepreneurs other
Forbes 30 under 30 recipients like
people that I look up to and I had a
line of people
wanting to talk to me and shake my hand
and take a picture with me some people
were like I can't believe how open you
are with your you know mental health
like good for you but like I would never
be but then some people were like wow
like you talking about that like I like
have OCD like Whispering it to me and
stuff and and even just that is I know
so hard in a world where you're supposed
to be emotionless and Fierce and tough
and make all the right decisions and be
perfect you know a CEO wouldn't say uh
wouldn't be embarrassed about telling
people that they had a heart problem or
diabetes so why should somebody be
embarrassed about saying that they have
a mental health disorder and so I
thought you know how can I basically
change the narrative around mental
health and make it so that it is treated
like normal health and it's actually
cool to talk about it and so that's when
you know Wonder mind kind of came to be
and Selena Gomez and Mandy Tiffy are my
co-founders and it was just really
important for us to set up an ecosystem
that made it okay and fun and cool and
trendy and exciting to learn about
mental health and learn about how the
most powerful people in the world the
people who are like this on the cover of
Forbes you know how they deal with their
anxiety or their mental health because
truly that's how I felt comfortable
enough to say something the people I'm
hoping to reach are not the people who
are actively trying to find a therapist
of course we want to reach them and we
have oven it's great we're looking for
the people who maybe have thought about
it but thought oh you know like I might
see a therapist and their friends like
why you have a problem I have
accomplished things that I didn't even
know I could dream about I didn't even
think that it was a possibility ever
people who are not you know ivy league
students people who are from minorities
people who come from different
backgrounds they don't have you know all
of this pedigree they don't have
connections you know all that stuff
those people should feel like they have
a chance they shouldn't count themselves
out because I counted myself out and the
only reason why I'm sitting in this
chair is because I was in survival mode
and I had no other choice and I am
stubborn as hell and it shouldn't be
like that for other people and so the
next five years I want to continue
investing in entrepreneurs especially
entrepreneurs that like me are not the
conventional you know let me invest in
you type
[Music]